joining us here on the rich eisen show
is the head coach of liberty football uh
thrilled to have here uh on the program
with his uh his quarterback um from the
last couple years shooting up the charts
right now to say the least malik willis
we're referring to on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line here on the rich eisen
show is hugh freeze how are you coach
i'm doing great rich thanks for having
me on you bet um i have not met in
person
malik willis but i've heard nothing but
remarkable things about him when was the
first time he crossed your radar screen
hugh freeze well i was uh i was coaching
uh at ole miss when he
was doing well in high school in roswell
georgia
so i i knew of him
we did not
actively recruit him then
um as he was committed fairly early
first to virginia tech then to auburn
so
didn't get to know him real well through
the process at all
so
a few years pass and
you know i show up at liberty and
he decides to transfer out of auburn
after
spring when he
just hadn't had had really no quality
reps there at all
and so that was when you know
i was intrigued because i knew the type
of athlete he was and i knew
um
in my opinion at these uh
at most colleges outside the top echelon
you know finding offensive linemen is
probably the hardest thing we have to do
and
you know i know
at my previous stops athletic
quarterbacks have always benefited our
system
and so i was very intrigued
didn't have
you know the only reps i had to really
watch was him going in i think he had a
total of like 15 snaps and they were
mostly all zone reads and
so then it's a matter of getting to know
him and then deciding do we think he can
be an adequate passer and
you know he sent me the videos of him
working out we got to know each other we
brought him up on a visit
fell in love with him as a kid
um and and
then it's just i kind of had to go with
my gut
and um
you know can we win football games with
with with this young man and
i really believe we could
and had no clue
that we would be you know talking on
your show today
about him being drafted in the first
round at that point
but it was
you know four to five games into his
first season that i thought man
he's a lot better than
we gave him credit for
and he just just continued to improve
and i just i think the sky's the limit
because
i mean we're talking about a guy that's
only played quarterback for two years
and you know i watching him work out at
the combine was just eye-popping um you
know his arm and what he was doing with
it and
the deep balls that he was heaving in
the
uh lucas oil stadium you know night was
i'll be honest reminiscent a little bit
of of what i saw from josh allen a
couple of years ago where he's just
fading back around a 10-yard line and
launching it and there it goes on the
other 30-yard line just dropped into a
bucket so you could see the the arm
strength
um what about his readiness do you think
though at the next level
hugh freeze and the questions that
you're hearing about that
regarding malik willis you know that's
uh obviously um pretty much daily right
now you know have talks with
with some teams and at the senior bowl
met with a lot and then obviously our
pro day and and now the calls continue
as he's
making his rounds to different uh
sites to to visit with those teams and i
think that's the
that's the question that um you know
that everyone has to answer and my my
response is
um
in this draft
um i just i don't see
anyone that has and nothing against you
know and i recruited matt corral and he
was committed to me before i left ole
miss and
and and i love
i think he's a great quarterback too but
i don't believe in this this draft that
there's one that has a higher ceiling
uh than malik and it's like i tell the
general managers and head coaches that
we're here what he doesn't know richie
doesn't know it's not because he can't
do it or he just is he's still young in
this process so
but when you watch i don't get to watch
a lot of nfl because of our schedule but
i do get to see the playoffs and
when i watched the playoffs last year
the one thing that i thought was eye
popping and
and i thought was pretty consistent in
about every game i watched is everyone
struggles to protect the quarterback
with these incredible defensive lines
that they have and so to have a guy
that can extend plays that create
opportunities to stay on the field
when things
don't go exactly as you have drawn up
and that has the arm strength and
incredible malik has the best balance
of probably any running back i've ever
had
and he's so physically strong and
balanced and you combine that with his
ability to extend plays and at the same
time
i think he's proven
that he has continued to improve when
just being in the pocket
and reading through progression so
i just i believe he has the highest
ceiling and one of the greatest things
that i think he brings to your locker
room is just his humility
to where if you told him hey you're not
quite ready you're the backup great
coach
let me know what i can do to help us win
if you looked at him and said malik you
you won it you're starting great
i mean he's got the same response to
both
and
um i just think he makes your whole team
better and he gives you
that what i think most nfl teams that
were in the final four to six to eight
kind of resembled people that are like
malik at the quarterback position hugh
freeze head coach of liberty football
here on the rich eisen show were talking
about his quarterback malik willis who
is uh truly um got a ton of buzz around
him right now um three weeks in one day
before the nfl draft in las vegas nevada
you mentioned a couple times now about
malik the person and um
the video i'm sure you have seen it that
went viral from the combine was captured
by a member of the media having lunch
across the street
um uh from a corner in indianapolis
where they spot malik willis opening up
what appeared to be you know a swag bag
that he just received and giving um
some what looks like a hat or just some
warm clothing to a person sitting on um
a carton on a street corner clearly
needing some help
and
what this was you know he had no idea
who he was being captured he had no idea
that this was being posted and this is
just him
you know
being what appears to be just him so
what can you tell me about him
that is him that that is him all day i'm
shocked even he would have given the
whole suitcase if uh if they if he'd
have felt
that they needed it and
he he's just that way he's done that
ever since he's been here
at our most recent
bowl game
you know you do the community service
events and we kind of scatter those you
know rotate through our roster to
to where everybody doesn't have to do
every single one of those and
um the
the uh our personnel department kind of
heads that up for us and they made a a
critical error and
the day before the game it was the last
community service event and and they
waited and had the d-line assigned to
that well you don't do that you let the
d-line go first early in the week
because
after that practice there many of the
d-line were complaining to our personnel
people and you know i'd already left and
headed back to watch film and get ready
for the game
and the type of person malik is he just
steps up and said that's fine if they
don't want to go me in the office flying
i'll do another shift and we'll go
and and he did and now the d-line went
with him of course but that's the type
of guy he is and leader he is and he's
he's just been that consistent
with that throughout his
his time here and
he's just uh i called him last night
just to check in on him and
and man he just has that same that
spirit about him that makes everybody
around him better
i can't wait to meet him i'll be honest
with you i really wanna you're really
gonna like him i mean he is as genuine
and as um
i mean he he's like a little kid at
heart
and that's the way he practices that
would drive me crazy sometimes what do
you mean
um so you just uh we just dropped a pass
in the red zone in practice and i'm
furious or
we made the wrong read or we fumbled and
here he is over there with the defense
congratulating them on making a play and
i'm wanting to just jerk him over there
you know and and his whole deal oh coach
we'll make the next one we'll make it
you know
and he's just and he believes that that
that he will but
and that's why i was i was at the senior
bowl meeting with one of the general
managers up top and i was trying to
explain
to them this same thing and i said you
know what instead of me explaining it
can we just step to the window and watch
him
and i think you'll see because i know
him so well and sure enough
he did his reps
and after his rest are over he's over
here talking to some defensive end
laughing and joking and then they break
and the quarterback coach take the
others and and here he is still talking
to this defensive end and then he's got
a sprint over there because he's late to
his drill i said that's what i'm talking
about that's the kind of kid you're
getting but everybody loves being around
him
and um and so it's um
he's just a special individual and i
think you'll see it when you meet him
so what are you hearing about from teams
then uh
what what are you hearing about what do
you think rich this is the most confused
i had a lot of first-rounders when i was
at ole miss right
and i kind of had an idea i have no clue
on this one
um
you know i know
the teams that have spent an enormous
amount of time visiting with me
you know whether it's carolina or
pittsburgh or atlanta
um
you know all of those have spent
seahawks
have spent a lot of time with us and
but it's hard for me to keep up we're in
the middle of spring practice with all
the free agency and who's taking
quarterbacks and who's not and
when they're going to take them and
it's very i called him last night he
told me where his rotation was of where
he was all going to visit which none
really surprised me philadelphia is
called here recently i talked to them a
lot last night
um
and so i just but i i don't think malik
i asked him man do you really have he
said i have no clue coach and um
it's kind of difficult for me to to
judge
kind of
ever how they're they're holding their
cars pretty well
philadelphia huh so was that is that uh
you got your talk to howie roseman you
talked to
no i talked to coach panunzio last night
i think he's in their personnel uh we go
back from our days in the sec together
but uh he was definitely calling
on behalf of them with some
just some more conversation
who else who else you spoke to hugh
freeze what do you got oh gosh i mean
everybody really you know
well i shouldn't say everybody but
everyone was here and and it i tried to
visit with as many as i could but again
i mentioned earlier the ones that i
think
you know have have spent the most time
whether it was
washington early on at the senior bowl
you know was was very
met with them
again atlanta seattle
what about pittsburgh oh yeah love
pittsburgh love tomlin man what a great
guy he is
you know i i like him a lot um again
can't really tell
i think they like malik a lot
carolina spent a lot of time with also
so
um i know they have genuine interest but
to to say
you know what they're really thinking i
really have no clue how about it i mean
this what an intriguing fascinating what
do you hear oh man i i i don't know are
you here well please i mean i hear
everything and
i mean there's smoke there's fire and
then there's really a big pile of you
know what you know what i mean and you
have no idea which is what or what's
which and you hear the saints just trade
it up you know into the first round
again maybe they're going to use that
fire power to go all the way up in front
of uh carolina at six to get the
quarterback they want or they're just
gonna sit there and maybe malik falls to
him there or maybe pickett falls from
there or they won't no quarterbacks
you're you're right it's very difficult
to get a read out of this hugh freeze
it is for me this year typically you
know all right these four quarterbacks
are going in the first round somewhere
and this year i
i truthfully just have no clue
hugh freeze thank you for the time let's
uh let's do this again truly appreciate
your time thank you so much for having
me you got it that is hugh freeze
liberty head coach here on the rich
eisen show
send that one to philadelphia w.i.p here
and you
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here